WE ARE THE SWORN ENEMY OF OF
LYING, POMPOSITY, SMUGNESS AND
GROUP THINK.
HAVE THE BEST WEEKEND.
>> Sean: HASN'T.
"HANNITY."
TONIGHT A MAJOR BREAKING NEWS.
A LETTER FROM DEVIN NUNES
SURROUNDING A SHADY FOREIGN
FIGURE NAMED JOSEPH MISFUD WHO
IS LINKED TO THE ORIGINS OF THE
FBI'S RUSSIA WITCH HUNT.
MUELLER PORTRAYED HIM AS AN
ACADEMIC WITH TIES TO RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
THE LETTER MAKES CLEAR ME MAY
HAVE CONNECTIONS TO RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENTS.
THAT RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION GOT
STARTED AND HOW INTELLIGENCE
SOURCES WERE COMPROMISED.
CONGRESS DEVIN NUNES WILL BE
HERE IN A MOMENT WITH A LOT
MORE.
AND HOW JAMES COMEY, HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR BEST
FRIENDS, THEIR MEDIA MOB WORKED
IN CONCERT TO CREATE AND
PERPETRATE A HOKE AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP AND YOU, WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT BREAKING
NEWS, I WANT YOU TO LISTEN
CLOSELY.
I KNOW YOU WON'T HEAR THIS GOOD
NEWS FROM ANY OTHER NEWS SOURCE:
TODAY'S ECONOMIC NEWS IS MORE
THAN PHENOMENAL.
WE HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT IS
BOOMING LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS.
THEY SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
UNEMPLOYMENT 3.6%.
THAT'S A 49 YEAR LOW.
WE ARE WITNESSING THE LOWEST
HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT EVER IN
OUR HISTORY.
HISTORIC LOWS FOR WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, AND YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
RECORD LEVELS OF JOBS FOR HIGH
SCHOOL DROPOUTS AND THOSE
WITHOUT A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
NATIONWIDE INCOME SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES.
THE STOCK MARKET IS SOARING.
THE U.S. IS A NET EXPORT OR OF
OIL AND GAS.
ENERGY INDEPENDENT FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 75 YEARS.
THAT'S A MAJOR NATIONAL SECURITY
WIN.
AGAINST THE HOSTILE ACTOR PUTIN
AND RUSSIA AND THEIR OIL BASED
OLIGARCHY.
EXPORTS OF GAS TO EUROPE
INCREASED 300% AFTER THE
PRESIDENT NEGOTIATED NEW TRADE
DEALS.
EUROPE'S ECONOMY, THEIR GROWTH A
WHOPPING LOW IN THE LAST 6
MONTHS.
OUR FIRST QUARTER GROWTH, 3.2%
DURING A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
THE ENVY OF THE WORLD.
NOW IN THE TRUMP ECONOMY,
EVERYBODY WINS.
AMERICAN GREATNESS IS RETURNING.
WITH THE 2020 ELECTION AROUND
THE CORNER, WHAT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC MESSAGE?
FEAR, DIVISION, THE WORLD ENDING
IN 10 YEARS.
NO MORE OIL, GAS, PLANES OR
COMBUSTION ENGINES.
WILL BIDEN DEFEND THE 8 YEARS OF
HIM AND OBAMA?
WHAT WAS THE SINGLE BIGGEST
ABECAUSE OF POWER SCANDAL IN
THIS COUNTRY'S HISTORY?
THE MOST SENSITIVE AND POWERFUL
INTELLIGENCE TOOLS WERE TURNED
AGAINST ITS OWN CITIZENS BY A
FEW AND NOT THE MAJORITY.
THE TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM, IT'S
BEYOND ALL DOUBT.
THEY WERE SPIED ON BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
LIVES WERE RUINED.
A PARTISAN SPECIAL COUNSEL WITCH
HUNT DIVIDED THIS COUNTRY FOR
ALMOST 2 YEARS.
IN THE END THEY LOST.
NO COLLUSION.
THE HOAX, WHETHER THEY ADMIT IT
OR NOT, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
CONFIRMED THEY ARE OVER.
STAGE-2, THE SECOND ACT BEGINS
OFFICIALLY.
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR 2 YEARS, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILL BEGIN
INVESTIGATING.
>> THERE HAS BEEN NO PRESIDENT
IN HISTORY THAT HAS GIVEN WHAT I
HAVE GIVEN IN A TOTAL WITCH
HUNT.
I CALL AT THIS TIME RUSSIAN
HOAX.
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION.
IT WAS A HOAX.
WE GAVE 1.4 MILLION DOCUMENTS
AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE.
I LET HIM INTERVIEW THE LAWYER,
THE WHITE HOUSE LAWYER FOR 30
HOURS!
I LET HIM INTERVIEW OTHER
PEOPLE.
I DIDN'T HAVE TO LET THEM
INTERVIEW ANYBODY.
I DIDN'T HAVE HAVE TO GIVE
NEDOCUMENTS.
-- ANY DOCUMENTS.
IT TURNED OUT I DID NOTHING
WRONG.
>> Sean: NOT ONCE DID THIS
ADMINISTRATION INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
THE SEARCH FOR JUSTICE IS
BEGINNING.
OPERATION CROSS FIRE HURRICANE.
IT'S THE BEGINNING OF OPERATION
BOOMERANG.
THESE BAD ACTORS WERE ACCUSING
THE PRESIDENT OF MISDEEDS, THEY
WERE THE ONES COMMITTING A
LITANY OF REAL TIMES.
-- OF REAL CRIMES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLS IT A SCAND
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLS IT A SCA D
SCANDAL BIGGER THAN WATERGATE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A FEW,
SELECT POWER-HUNGRY, THOSE WHO
VIEW THEMSELVES AS
SUPER-PATRIOTS WHO THINK WE
DON'T KNOW BETTER.
THOSE THAT RIGGED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY AND
TRIED TO RIG AN ELECTION AND SET
UP THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WITH AN
INSURANCE POLICY AND TRIED TO
TAKE DOWN THE ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE BASIC AND FUNDAMENTAL TRUTH.
IT'S SO SIMPLE EVEN THESE LAZY
OVERPAID MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA.
SO-CALLED JOURNALIST, THE 99%
THAT GOT IT WRONG AND LIED TO
EVERYBODY.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED ON
THAT.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" EVEN
ADMITTING THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
COVERING FOR YEARS.
WITH THE REPORT THAT DETAILS HOW
COMEY'S FBI, IT'S DEEPER THAN WE
THOUGHT.
THEY SENT AN UNDER-COVER
INVESTIGATOR POSING AS A
RESEARCH ASSISTANT MEETING WITH
THE TRUMP AIDE GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
THE UNDER-COVER AGENT SET UP THE
MEETING IN LONDON WITH HERSELF,
A 30-YEAR-OLD BLOND MAKING IT
KNOWN SHE'S AVAILABLE WITH
PAPADOPOULOS AND THIS WAS
SUPPOSED TO INVOLVE FOREIGN
POLICY STRATEGIES BUT TOOK A
WEIRD, UNUSUAL TURN.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA AND TRUMP, TRUMP, TRUMP
AND WHETHER THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WAS WORKING WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IT'S MORE BIZARRE.
THE UNDER-COVER AGENT WAS TRYING
TO SEDUCE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ADVISOR POMADES.
-- PAPADOPOULOS.
HE IS HERE TONIGHT TO TELL US
THIS STORY.
THE FBI WAS SPYING ON PAGE'S
PHONE CALLS AND EMAILS AFTER HE
WAS WIRETAPPED PURSUANT TO A
FISAA WARRANT SIGNED BY JAMES
COMEY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
PUT TOGETHER WITH RUSSIAN LIES
AND GOOGLE SEARCHES.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE THEY DOCUMENT
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" COULD HAVE BEEN
DISINFORMATION FROM RUSSIA.
NOW THE SUBJECT OF AN
INVESTIGATION BEING CONDUCTED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE SAID THIS WEEK, HE IS NOT
CHANGING HIS MIND ON MUELLER.
IT'S OVER.
IT'S DONE AND FINISHED.
ANYTHING FROM HERE ON IN IS
NOISE.
WHAT HE SAYS NOW IS WHAT THE
SECOND ACT IS GOING TO BE ALL
ABOUT.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW DO WE KNOW THAT THE
STEELE DOSSIER IS NOT ITSELF
EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN?
KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW NOW, THE
ALLEGATIONS MADE WERE
SECOND-HAND HEARSAY OR
UNVERIFIED?
CAN YOU STAY THE STEELE DOSSIER
WAS NOT PART OF THE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN?
>> NO, I CAN'T STATE THAT WITH
CONFIDENCE.
-- THAT'S ONE AREA I AM
REVIEWING.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ENTIRELY
SPECULATIVE.
>> Sean: THIS IS JUST THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG.
WE HAVE BARR'S INVESTIGATION
INTO SPYING AND FISA COURT
PROUD.
-- FRAUD.
SO MANY OTHER PROBES.
WHY DID THEY RIG THE HILLARY
CLINTON INVESTIGATION?
IN OTHER WORDS, WE MUST GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF WHAT WAS THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER SCANDAL
IN HISTORY.
IF WE DIDN'T, WE CAN NO LONGER
CONSIDER OURSELVES A
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
THE VICE-PRESIDENT IS OF THE
UNITED STATES IS VOWING TO DO
JUST THAT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'VE GOT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF HOW ALL OF THIS
STARTED.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW HOW THIS INVESTIGATION
EVEN BEGAN.
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
TESTIFYING BEFORE CONGRESS,
THERE WAS SPYING IS.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
>> WERE YOU SPIED ON?
>> WE NEED TO FIND OUT AND GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF HOW THIS ALL
BEGAN.
IF THE LAW WAS BROKEN, THE
PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE NEED TO BE
HELD ACT BELIEVE.
>> Sean: HELL HAS FROZEN OFF.
EVEN MSNBC MIGHT BE STARTING TO
SEE THE LIGHT.
ONLY ONE.
DON'T GET CARRIED AWAY.
AGREEING WITH THE VICE-PRESIDENT
THAT SPYING OCCURRED.
REMEMBER, NOTHING BUT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES EVERY SECOND, MINUTE,
HOUR OF EVERY DAY FOR 2 YEARS ON
THIS CONSPIRACY TV CHANNEL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET ME START WITH A CENTRAL
QUESTION IN A LOT OF PEOPLE'S
MINDS AS THEY FIRST READ IT.
HOW IS THIS NOT SPYING?
>> WELL, IT DEPENDS ON YOUR
DEFINITION OF SPYING.
>> Sean: THIS HAS SERIOUS
RAMIFICATIONS FOR THE 2020
ELECTION.
NOT LOOKING GOOD FOR CREEPY
UNCLE JOE.
HE WAS IN THE MEETINGS WITH
COMEY, OBAMA AND RICE ABOUT THE
DIRTY DOSSIER?
WHAT DID HE KNOW?
AND BIDEN'S SHADY DEALINGS WITH
THE UKRAINE.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," HE DID USE HIS POSITION
AS THE VICE-PRESIDENT.
HE THREATENED TO WITHHOLD OUR
MONEY.
THE TAXPAYER'S MONEY.
A BILLION DOLLARS IN U.S. LOAN
GUARANTEES IF UKRAINES LEADERS
DID NOT IN 6 HOURS DISMISS THE
COUNTRY'S TOP PROSECUTOR WHO WE
KNOW IS INVESTIGATING CORRUPTION
ACCUSATIONS AT A UKRAINE ENERGY
FIRM WHERE BIDEN'S SON SERVED ON
THE BOARD.
HE HAS THE WORST ECONOMIC RECORD
IN 8 YEARS OF OBAMA.
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS AND 8 MILLION MORE
ON POVERTY.
COMPARED TO THE TRUMP ECONOMY.
ALL OF THESE RECORDS BROKEN.
HILLARY CLINTON, WELL, SHE AND
HER FELLOW DEMOCRACY ACCUSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF COLLUDING
WITH A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
THEY WERE THE ONES DOING THE
COLLUDING.
LOOKING AT THIS DAMNING REPORT
FROM THE HILLS JOHN SOLOMAN.
ACCUSING THE DNC TO ACCORD TO
AFFECT THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
A CONTRACTOR TRIED TO ARRANGE
FOR THE UKRAINE PRESIDENT TO
COMMENT ON PAUL MANAFORT'S
RUSSIAN TIES DURING THE 2016
CAMPAIGN AND EMAIL EVIDENCE.
THE LEFT HAS A LOT TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT TONIGHT.
THEY WERE USING THE MOST
SENSITIVE, POWERFUL TOOLS IN OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
TURNING IT ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, TO BLUDGEON THE
CANDIDATE THEY DIDN'T LIKE IN
FAVOR OF THE CANDIDATE THEY
THOUGHT SHOULD WIN 100 MILLION
TO 0 AND ADD AN INSURANCE
POLICY.
WE ARE JUST SMELLY WAL-MART
VOTERS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW?
THEY WERE COLLUDING WITH THE
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT TO IMPACT THE
ELECTION.
THEY DIVIDED THIS COUNTRY FOR
OVER 2 YEARS WITH LIE AFTER LIE
AND A FULL-ON HOAX.
THEY ARE THE ONES WEAPONIZING
OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM AGAINST
ITSELF.
NOW THEY ARE THE ONES LASHING
OUT TRYING TO DISTRACT FROM
THEIR CRIMES AND ACCORDING TO A
GREAT NEW OP-ED FROM THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL," BARR IS
ATTACKED BECAUSE HIS PROBE
ENDANGERS POWERFUL PEOPLE.
THE ACTION OF HILLARY CLINTON,
JAMES COMEY, ANDREW DOLE AND JOE
BIDEN AND PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE AND EVEN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HIMSELF OBAMA ARE NOW
COMING INTO FOCUS.
WE WILL GET ANSWERS.
SUNLIGHT IS THE BEST
DISINFECTANT.
THE PENDULEUM HAS SWUNG.
THE MUELLER ISSUE IS DONE.